Musik
Ach, schön, dass ihr da seid. Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von DPU, der Podcast-UFO-Podcast. Mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich wieder Stefan und der Titzler. Schön, dass du da bist. Servus, grüß dich. Servus, hallo, Florian Will sitzt mir gegenüber wohlgesunden. Wohlgenährt, muss man sagen. Du hast gerade sehr viel Nudeln gegessen. Ich habe vergessen zu essen. Heißt, ihr könnt ja mal nach der Folge in die Kommentare schreiben. Gibt es sowas noch? Weiß ich nicht. Wer von uns beiden quasi anderperformed hat. Ja, wir haben harte Sättigungsgefälle. Ich habe schon vorgeschlagen, dass ich dich wie so eine Vogelmutter fütter, indem ich einfach ein bisschen was von meinen Spaghetti hochwürge und dir in den Mund spucke. Finden Vögel das auch sauecklich? Ich glaube, die finden das auch fucking ecklich. Schnell dir mal vor, du bist so ein Vogelsohn. Und du bist so, und gegenüber auf dem Arzt sitzt Joey, der coole Klassensjog-Vogel. Ja, der hat schon bunte Federn und du bist noch ganz braun. Der hat schon bunte Federn und einen wunderschönen Gesang, dass man sich auch fragt, stehe ich vielleicht auf männliche Vögel? So, der wunderschön Gesang. Und genau in dem Moment kommt deine Vogelmutter an und kotzt dir in den Mund. Mama! Erstmal, ist das dann peinlich dann vor Joey halt in den schönen bunten Federn? Ich glaube, es ist auch generell einfach ekelig. Es ist ekelig, ist natürlich auch die Frage, wo in der Hackerordnung du bist. Kriegst du als erstes schön das in den Schnabel gestopft oder bist du das letzte Kind, wo einfach noch hauptsächlich Magensäfte eine Rolle spielen. Irgendwie schön, wo du einfach reindrückst. Von daher, ich glaube, es ist unangenehm. Das ist ja ein Stimmelchen, da kommen wir noch raus. Nur für die letzten Sachen. Mir wäre es ja richtig unangenehm, mich zu übergeben. Gar nicht so sehr wegen der ganzen Geruchsimplikationen oder so, sondern einfach, weil Leute sehen, was ich gegessen habe, weil man guckt ja dann schon mal hin, also das ist ja, wir müssen ja jetzt alle nicht so tun, als wären wir besser, als wir sind, man guckt ja dann schon mal rein, das ist ja dann schon so ein bisschen wie der Verlauf, wie wenn du die Chance hast, bei jemandem den Chrome-Verlauf zu lesen, das Erbrochene ist ja so ein bisschen der Essensverlauf, und dann schaut man rein und dann fragt man sich schon nicht mal, was ist das irgendwie?
Ein komplettes Kinder-Bueno noch in Verpackung? Wie kommt das da rein?
Es ist tatsächlich wie der Browser-Verlauf, nur
wurden halt beim Erbrechen
werden die Cookies ein paar Mal häufiger gelöscht, oder der Verlauf.
Weil du hast
du hast nicht das von den letzten
Monaten drin, sondern nur das von den letzten
paar Stunden. Das stimmt, ja.
Und auch in der falschen Reihenfolge vielleicht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht. Wird im Magen
eigentlich durchgemischt?
Also gibt es im Magen so eine Art Betonmischer
oder wird das, was du als
erstes isst, auch als erstes verdaut?
Also wenn du jetzt nicht erbrechen würdest,
würdest du dann in umgekehrter Reihenfolge
der Aufnahme dann auch wirklich erbrechen?
Da gehe ich schon von aus. Also erst
das Dessert,
dann der Hauptgang, dann Salat
und dann noch mal schön
Vielen Dank. der Aufnahme dann auch wirklich erbrechen. Da gehe ich schon von aus. Also erst das Dessert, dann der Hauptgang, dann Salat und dann nochmal schön vom Vormorgen das Wurstbrot. Genau. Ich glaube, genau so. Also in umgekehrter Reihenfolge. Und ja, also ich bin auch der Schnelleresser, heisst ich kau nicht richtig wahrscheinlich. Und mehr oder weniger, weil so Comic-Comic-mä-mäßig, wenn man sich so SpongeBob vorstellt,
der kotzt, Comics bleibt dann wieder,
kommt das ganze Essen ja wieder raus,
so ein grosser Burger. Ja, das stimmt,
wenn du gar nicht gekaust, ist das ein Vorteil.
So ein Comic-mäßig. Ich habe die Vorstellung, dass du einfach über ein ganzes Wochenende extrem
aufwendig kochst, irgendwie schön blanchierter
Spargel, Rindereintopf
auskochen lassen, schön noch die Parmesan-Rinden
aufgehoben, vom letzten
Monat rein da, schön ein bisschen herzhaften
und dann wirklich alles wird schön durchgekocht und dann stopft sie das innerhalb von eineinhalb Minuten nicht rein. Einfach das große Fressen mit Würgen und wirklich schön die ganze Lammkeule einfach rein, ohne dass gekaut wird. Einfach rein, Knochen und so auch einfach komplett reinschieben.
Generell meine Erfahrung, man kann mehr
essen, als man denkt. Dieser
Plastiküberzug vom
Käse, den viele
abfriemeln aufwendig.
Glaub mir, man kann den essen.
Das ist schon okay, also da
passiert jetzt auch nicht viel. Die Kiwischale,
wo viele sagen, ich hole einen Löffel
rein, glaub mir, du kannst die Kiwischale mitessen. Und wenn du dieses Pflaumgefühl nicht willst, dann gehst du einmal mit dem Rasierer drüber. Ist doch kein Problem. Dann nimmst du schön Manscaped diesen Rasierer und ballerst den mal drüber. Finde ich völlig okay. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein klassischer Test für neue Rasierer, ist der Kiwi-Test. Ich glaube, du kannst es wirklich gut machen. Die Kiwi ist zum Rasierer, wie die Tomate zur Zahnbürste ist. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, das ist äquivalent. Aber ich finde es auch einfach gut, dass es manche Obstsorten gibt, die Haare haben. Da hat auch einfach der Schöpfer einfach mal durchgemischt und copy-paste, was habe ich gerade noch rumliegen, was muss noch weg? Herrchen. Ich habe noch Haare, gibt der Biene mal Haare? Warum? Gibt der Haare? Gibt es blonde Kiwis? Und gibt es Langhaar? Mit Strähnchen? Gibt es so Langhaar Kiwis? Also werden Bumbra-Effekt? Sind die Kiwis quasi mit der Kurzhaarfrisur, wie wir sie alle kennen, diese Drei-Tage-Bartfrisur, sind die da einfach reif und bekommen die irgendwann prachtvolle so einen Haarschopf und so ein Zöpfchen oder bleiben die so?
Ich habe auch noch nie eine Kiwi am Baume gesehen, wo man wirklich sagt, bevor die geerntet wird,
wie die da aussieht, wie die einfach so einen schönen Fokuhila dann auch nochmal hat am Baum.
Und der muss dann erst aufwendig vor Ort, macht man natürlich vor Ort, wird der dann einfach kahl rasiert.
In der Schale stecken die ganzen Vitamine, genau wie beim Babybill auch.
Und Babybill deswegen auch einfach unbedenklich mit dem Wachs essen. Warum sind die Vitamine, man sagt immer, die Vitamine sind unter der Schale. Das ist so die zweite Line of Defense. Zuerst Schale und dann schickt die Vitamine und dann, nein, das süße Fruchtfleisch wird angegriffen vom Raben oder was auch immer. Ich verstehe es auch nicht, warum die sich genau den Ort suchen. Das ist so Vorort. Die Vitamine sind Vorort.
Die schicken Suburbs.
Ja, genau so. Ja, wir ziehen jetzt ein bisschen, wo es ruhiger ist. Ah, okay. Seitdem ihr Vitamine seid, seid ihr irgendwie ganz schön abgehoben. Ja, wir haben jetzt irgendwie da, wo B12 ist, wollen wir jetzt auch, haben wir eine schöne Wohnung gefunden für C. Und also C4 und C3 sind ja alle in einer Nachbarschaft. Das ist sehr homogen, das gefällt uns sehr gern. Ja, und wir,, keine Ahnung, Glucose sind und irgendwie in der Mitte hocken, im Ghetto hocken wir, wollen eigentlich auch gerne mal Vitamine werden und raus aufs Land ziehen. Ja, vielleicht eines Tages, vielleicht werden wir auch Vitamine. Ist es auch so wie bei Tieren, wo der Wurm sagt, ich wäre gern Schmetterling, dass mal so eine Glucose-Verbindung sagt, ach, ich wäre gern Enzym, auch vielleicht eines Tages, aber aber der Chemiker weiß, nein, wird nicht passieren, mein Freund. Sind Motten vorher auch Raupen? Äh, ich glaube, die haben dann, nee, ich glaube, die haben dann wieder das Eiersystem dann doch wieder. Man sagt ja Motteneier und so, also ich glaube, also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist es... Es ist ein Ei und daraus schlüpft eine Raupe und daraus also die die haben wirklich alle Stufen und dann irgendwie Pubertät erstmal, also du hast als Ei eine Pubertät, dann hast du als Raupe nochmal eine Pubertät und dann als Motta auch nochmal. Also dreimal Linken Park. Dreimal entdeckst du deinen Körper, dreimal entdeckst du einen anderen Körper. Ja, du musst jeden Körper neu entdecken. Du musst alle Körper neu entdecken, ist immer alles anders. Verrückt eigentlich, ne, auch wenn du dann wirklich sich mal so erlebst, also so eine Raupe auch sich mal sinnlich wirklich erlebt. Stell dir vor, du bist so die schönste Raupe. Schöner als alle anderen Raupen. Ja, bunt, schick und auch so Herrchen und stolze Herrchen und stolzen Kopf. Und dann bist du auch sehr schnell, so auf dem Trainingscourt, kannst schnell kriechen, weil du hast es einfach raus, du hast es raus, du kannst mit den Muskelkontraktionen und den ganzen Beinchen, kannst du sehr schnell kriechen. Haben wir Beinchen? Weiß ich nicht, Körper noch nicht entdeckt. So, kriegst jedenfalls schnell los und dann irgendwann hast du dieses Verdanken, dich einzukokonieren und bist dann ein wunderschöner Schmetterling oder eine wunderschöne Motte, also eine richtig schöne Motte und bist dann nicht mehr die schönste, der schönste und kannst auch nicht mehr schnell fliegen meinetwegen. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Schule. In der Schule sind alle Raupen und alle ähnlich und alle haben aber Träume und dann erst so nach dem Abi kognieren sich alle ein und man merkt, oh, ich habe mit der Motte gar nicht mehr so viel zu tun, ich bin Schmetterling oder ich bin Frosch oder was auch immer irgendwie komplett falsch abgeboten. Nee, nee, du bist schon Schmetterling. Und dann einfach so, ach krass, man hat miteinander nichts mehr zu tun. Klar, so zwei, drei Schmetterlinge finden sich zusammen, die gründen dann irgendwie ein Start-up, aber man merkt irgendwann, oh krass. Oder eine Familie. Oder eine Familie, ja, die Motten machen eher Familie, die Schmetterlinge ihre Karriere und man merkt nach ein paar Jährchen so, oh, wir haben gar nicht mehr viel miteinander zu tun, wir haben uns auseinandergelebt. Und wir waren auch einfach andere Spezies, kann man auch mal. Ja, rückblickend, ja, das ist uns damals aber nicht aufgefallen. Rückblickend, wir waren einfach so anders, dass es komplett uns in die Wien gelegt war, uns nicht zu verstehen auch. Ja, kann sein. Und die ziehen dann zu den Vitaminen raus an die Schale oder wer zieht jetzt so? Nee, die beißen sich wieder, der Apfelwurm beißt sich dann von außen wieder durch, der will ja an die Vitamine ran. Ist es vielleicht so, damit der Wurm auch ein paar Vitamine mitkriegt, damit er auf dem Weg zum saftigen Fruchtfleisch auch ein paar Vitamine mitkriegt? Sind Vitamine, will niemand Vitamine essen und die Natur versucht, die ständig Leuten unterzumischen? Und überall, wo man denkt, oh, da muss ich durch, erst deine Vitamine, erst die Vitamine. Die Mutternatur ist wirklich die Mutter, so eine richtige Mutternatur. Bevor du ans Fruchtfleisch kommst, musst du erst mal die Vitamine essen. Deswegen schön unter der Schale, ist schon eine gute Idee. Die Natur ist eine Marm, aber du hast sehr viel Nudeln gefressen vor der Aufnahme. Habe ich mich reingestopft, wirklich unter Stress essen, ich musste noch irgendwas hochladen und musste unter Stress mich nicht reinschieben. Stimmt, das ist anstrengend, auch körperlich anstrengend, was hochzuladen, Internet zu riefen. Nee, wirklich, ich würde lieber selber an einem Rädchen drehen, um Dinge hochzuladen. Download ist entspannt, Download ist ja, das macht es ja von alleine, aber so ein Upload. Upload, da muss man richtig nochmal in die Eisen gehen. Ich würde lieber, ich sag's dir hier und jetzt, wenn ich einen Deal mit dem Teufel schließen müsste, hier und jetzt. Hallo! Guten Tag, Herr Satan, ich hätte eine Bitte, und zwar würde ich gerne, wenn ich was uplaude, also sei es jetzt ein Video für YouTube oder Podcast oder so, dann würde ich gerne haben, dass die Upload-Geschwindigkeit nicht von meiner Bandbreite abhängt, sondern ich an so einem kleinen Rädchen drehe.
Also dass ich selber beeinflussen kann, wie schnell das hochlädt.
Das können wir so machen. Und ich baue dir diese Apparatur. Aber die Seele des ersten Menschen, der hochgeladen wird, gehört mir und mir allein! Hahaha! Okay, gut. Hm, was mache ich jetzt? Ich will schon was hochladen jetzt, aber ich will auch meine Seele nicht verlieren, was auch immer das ... Moment mal, ich könnte dich ... Nein, nein, nein, nein, Brr, nein, Brr, nein, Brr, nein, alle meine Kinder haben ihre Seelen verloren, lass mir ein Kind, ein Ei, so ein Ei ist noch da. Ich hätte vor allem am liebsten als Teufel jetzt Jerry Seinfeld als Seele gehabt, wenn du so eine Folge Seinfeld hochgeladen hättest. Oh ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Nee, es ist anstrengend und man ist ja in den Händen des Digitalen, in den Händen des Digitalgottes und der ist manchmal launisch und man weiß es nicht. Deswegen großer Stress, viel Stress bei Ladebalken. Vielleicht muss der Ladebalken überdacht werden, weil der Ladebalken, ich glaube, nichts macht so viel Stress wie der Ladebalken, egal in welcher Form, sondern einfach statt dem Ladebalken einfach der Satz Alles ist gut. Solange du willst. Du hast Zeit. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich bin aber, ich habe gerade überlegt, ich bin eigentlich für mehr Ladebalken. Warum ist Ampel sowas, alles ist gut, du gleich grün, entspann dich, leh mich zurück, nimm einen Schluck Wasser. So ist die Ampel. Aber ich hätte lieber gerne so eine Ladung, so eine Ladeanzeige, die mir sagt, wann ist gleich grün.
Oder an der Kasse, so anstatt, oh, ich habe noch zwei Kunden vor mir, einfach so eine Anzeige, ab hier drei Minuten, so wie im Vergrüben-Pakt. Ja, ab hier drei Stunden.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine Vorform von Ladebalken, einfach zu sagen, ab hier noch fünf Minuten, ab hier noch neunzig Minuten.
Warum sind sie überhaupt noch hier? Sind Sie wirklich gewillt, 90 Minuten drauf zu warten? Gehen Sie nach Hause, legen Sie sich hin. Was ich noch lieber hätte, wäre ein Ladebalken, wo runter steht, wie ich meine Entscheidungen dann treffen soll, auf Basis dieser Ladeanzeige. Beispiel im Freizeitpark, ab hier noch 90 Minuten, in Klammern, lohnt sich nicht. Ja, genau Achterbahn. Es ist schon cool, aber 90 Minuten lohnt sich nicht. Wir haben geguckt, Sie können in der Zeit folgende Sachen machen. Hier fünf andere Attraktionen, die Sie in der Zeit easy schaffen. 100 Spanisch-Vokabeln, por favor, können Sie gerne machen. Genau. Das ist eine 70-Minuten-Achterbahn. Ab 70 Minuten, bis 70 Minuten lohnt es sich, darüber hinaus nicht. Wir haben das getestet, wissenschaftlich. So ist es einfach nicht.
Wir haben geguckt, wir geben diese Achterbahn acht von zehn Sparseinheiten. Sie können neun von zehn Sparseinheiten auf folgenden anderen Attraktionen sein. Ja genau, für ihr Spaßbuklet. Bist du eigentlich so ein Typ, du bist ja ein Freizeitparkfreak.
Connisseur.
Aber wie stehst du zu dieser aktuellen Bewegung, zu sagen, ich hole mir den Freizeitpark nach Hause, ich spreche von einer Zuckerwattemaschine, ich spreche von Popcornmaschinen, sowas, zu sagen, ich hole mir den Jahrmarkt nach Hause. Bist du da... Jahrmarkt, da bin ich ein altmodischer, old-fashioned Guy. Ich bin der Meinung, nein, der Freizeitpark soll im Freizeitpark bleiben. Okay. Was will ich zu Hause mit dem Freizeitpark? Hier ist kein Spaß. Zu Hause ist ein Ort der Arbeit und des Frustes. Da soll schön ... Da ist keine Zuckerwatte fahren. Da ist kein Platz für Spaß. Aber ich könnte mir eh nicht vorstellen, wer sich eine Zuckerwattemaschine nach Hause holt, um einfach abends zu sagen, jetzt nochmal einfach so in merkwürdige Wolkenform gepresster Zucker. Darauf hätte ich jetzt am meisten Lust. Und dann sitzt du zu Hause auf dem Sofa und hast eine riesige Zuckerwatte im Mund. Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich kann es mir auch nicht vorstellen, aber jetzt gerade wo du das sagst, ist es eigentlich das, was ich will.
Eigentlich schon. Popcornmaschine finde ich auch nicht so schlecht. Popcornmaschine finde ich auch, ich arbeite ja gerade an einem Startup aktuell, ich habe schon Investoren gefunden, und zwar, es gibt ja für alles Lieferservice, aber meine Idee, Lieferservice für Kinosnacks. Filme. Nee, Kinosnacks. Filmsnacks. Du machst einen schönen Filmabend zu Hause, Freunde da und du sagst, ey Leute, lass uns ein paar Tüten Popcorn, Nachos bestellen, eine Flasche Cola, zack, ist es in 20 Minuten da, geile Popcorn, du hast dann, ich stelle mir so ein Warenhaus vor, wo nur eine riesige Popcornmaschine steht, die beste der Welt, halt einfach so die Number One, einfach so wirklich die Machtreihe. Du willst so nachts, wenn das aus ist, der Laden, willst du da kurz nochmal reinsneaken und einfach in so ein Bad aus Popcorn reinspringen.
Nicht unbedingt, das ist nicht unbedingt der Grund, warum ich das Startup gegründet habe.
Ich will einfach den Leuten ermöglichen, Popcorn zum selben Preis wie im Kino sich zu Hause zu bestellen.
Aber ich glaube, die Kinolobby wirft mir da Stöcke in die Speichen, weil die ja tatsächlich den Hauptumsatz mit Kinosnacks machen, gar nicht mit dem Film. Film ist nur Nebenwerk, das ist einfach nur so nebenbei. Die könnten eigentlich auch eine Popcornhalle machen. Weißt du, das sagt man bei allen Sachen, sagt man das. Die Tankstellen, das ist richtig so, die Tankstellen machen nicht durch den Benzinumsatz, nein, durch die Snacks nebenbei. Ja, Restaurants verdienen durch die Getränke das Geld, nicht durch das Essen. So, können wir mal machen wir nicht alle was falsch dann? Wenn alle was durch was, ein Beiprodukt Geld verdienen, dann machen wir doch alle was falsch. Nein, also auch zum Beispiel so die Schokoküsse, die machen Geld nur durch die Waffel unten. Die machen eigentlich Verlust mit dem ganzen Schaum und der Schokolade, die machen nur Gewinn mit der Waffel tatsächlich. Wenn Tankstellen nur mit den Snacks Geld verdienen. Wie macht dann Snickers nur durch Tankstellen Geld? Durch Treibstoff. Die machen ja auch nur durch die Erdnüsse Geld. Auch da Karamell machen die harte Verluste. Verluste sogar. Die machen nur durch die Erdnuss Geld. Oder auch so Videospiele, die machen mit den Konsolen Verlust, aber mit den Spielen dann Gewinn. Das ist auch so eine weirte Welt. Ich glaube, das ist die wunderbare Welt der BWL, von der wir gar keine Ahnung haben. Wir sind Künstler, wir malen die Welt in bunten Farben, aber für solche Zahlenspielereien haben wir keinen Sinn. Haben wir gar keinen Sinn für, gar kein Gefühl für. Wir haben gar keinen Sinn. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es stimmt. Ich glaube, diese Lobby sagen das. Aber eigentlich machen die
schon alle Restaurants machen mit
Essengeld. Ja, ja. Aber ich habe es auch mal
gehört, zum Beispiel so BMW
macht primär Geld mit diesen Wunderbäumen.
Mit den Autos machen die Verlust,
aber durch diese Duftbäume
holen die richtig viel Geld rein. Wie Red Bull
macht der auch quasi nicht durch die
Drinks Geld, sondern durch die Formel 1.
Durch diese ganzen Extremsportveranstaltungen.ungen. Das ist schon verrückt, wie das funktioniert. Auch hier nochmal die Frage an euch. Wenn ihr da irgendwie eine Erklärung für uns habt, sagt Bescheid, wir wissen es nicht. Erklärt uns mal die Welt. Kannst du uns mal irgendwie die Welt erklären? Erklärt uns mal die Welt und vor allem tut das am besten in unserem Reddit. Denn wir wollen unser Reddit ein bisschen nach vorne bringen, weil wir kriegen immer ganz viele Nachrichten von euch mit tollen Elfchen, mit tollen Einsendungen. Und wir denken uns jetzt immer, wie schade ist das denn eigentlich, dass nur wir diese ganzen tollen Sachen lesen? Wäre doch cool, wenn die ganze Community das auch lesen könnte. Deswegen sagen wir jetzt, Leute, schreibt das am besten alle in unser Reddit, weil da können auch andere das lesen, da kann das auch gevotet werden, dann können wir so die bestbewerteten Sachen auch mit in die Sendung nehmen. Und wir sind auch natürlich, es ist einfacher für uns, quasi den besten Content von euch in die Sendung zu nehmen, weil wir nicht alles auf verschiedenen Plattformen geschickt bekommen, sondern dann würden wir es alle gebündelt da sammeln, in unserem Subreddit. Macht das einfach. Das ist ein wenig heist. Ihr könnt euch ja auch einen anonymen Account machen, also ihr müsst auch nicht euren Namen preisgeben, falls ihr das nicht wollt, kein Problem, schreibt das da rein, besucht uns auf unserem Reddit das Podcast UFO. Das Podcast UFO, könnt ihr euch beteiligen und dann könnt ihr uns da die Welt erklären und wir kriegen immer ganz tolle schlaue Sachen, auch zum Thema Bibelhumor, ganz viele tolle Sachen, die ihr euch auch durchlesen könnt und da könnt ihr natürlich auch eure ganzen Elfchen einmal sammeln, weil es hat sich mittlerweile echt eine grosse Community entwickelt von Elfchen-Konnesseuren und Konnesseurinnen, die da zusammen diese fantastische Kunstform zelebrieren. Finde ich richtig toll. Genau, und es wäre auch was für dich, Matze, denn Matze hat uns geschrieben Re-Hustlen. Wir haben nämlich letzte Woche die Hausaufgabe aufgegeben, dass ihr bei Leuten, die kein Englisch sprechen, mal das Wort Hasseln unterbringen müsst.
Sowas wie, ich muss diese Woche, habe ich gar keine Lust, wieder die ganze Zeit rumzuhasseln.
Es könnte deutsches Wort sein.
Meine These war, Leute verstehen das schon.
Und Mats hat uns geschrieben, er hat es nämlich bei seinem Vater untergebracht.
Er hat geschrieben, also seinem Vater gesagt wortwörtlich, ich muss mein MacBook für die Bachelorarbeit noch mit Software versehen, sodass ich demnächst damit nicht mehr rumhasseln muss. Er sagte, ja. Also, aber vielleicht muss man dazuschreiben, dass die Kommunikation zwischen Matze und seinem Vater ohnehin seit Jahren schwierig ist. Trocken und unemotional ist. Trocken und distanziert. Trocken, distanziert, aber sehr professionell. Und das fand ich mal gut, weil der Vater hat es entweder nicht verstanden. Oh, das war ihm scheißegal. Aber ich dachte jetzt gerade, ich wollte erst gerade sagen, gut, das hat jetzt die These verifiziert. Ja. Leute, die kein Englisch sprechen, verstehen, hassen. Ich dachte aber gerade, oder der Vater ist wie ich und behauptet einfach die ganze Zeit, er würde was verstehen. Wie oft lügst du? Bei solchen Sachen regelmäßig, akustisch nicht verstanden, ja, ja. Jetzt sind die Tage waren Handwerker bei mir, weil es in meinen Sicherungskasten regnet. Fun fact. Es regnet nur in deinem Sicherungskasten. Es regnet in meinem Sicherungsschacht. Es ist die ganze Wohnung trocken, aber es gibt Sturzbachartige Vorkommnisse in meinem Sicherungskasten. Sicherungskasten. Ich stelle mir so vor, das gesamte Regenwasser des gesamten Wohnblocks wird einfach geleitet auf einen Punkt, wo genau Stefan diese Sicherungskasten ist. Es ist ziemlich genau so, alle anderen. Und ich kam aus dem Urlaub wieder und die ganze Wohnung war dunkel und der Sicherungskasten klatschnass. Ist ein bisschen ein Problem. Und ist auch gar nicht so ungefährlich, ehrlich gesagt. Was du immer für einen Scheiss erlebst in deiner Wohnung. Erst diese Pollenbäume, die Mottenplage und jetzt Wasser im Kasten. Die Pollenbäume habe ich komplett vergessen. Diese Bälle an Pollen in meiner Wohnung. Aber es wechselt sich ab, das finde ich ganz gut. Es bleibt spannend. Es ist eine Erlebniswohnung. Und es sind interessante Gegner. Es sind nicht so die klassischen Feuer, Wasser, Luft, sondern auch irgendwie mal sowas wie Pollen und Motten und jetzt mit Wasser und Strom natürlich ein klassischer Kampf der Elemente. Ich bin gespannt, wie es aussieht. Genau wie bei einer Freundin von mir, die Fledermäuse bei sich in der Wohnung. Gott! Die leben da oder fliegen die irgendwo rein und wieder raus? Nee, das hat sie dir ja auch erzählt. Sie war ja hier, Theresa, auch eine gemeinsame Kollegin von uns, hat uns ja erzählt, dass sie Fledermaus-Problem bei sich hatte. Ja, sie wurde angegriffen. Und sich nicht zu helfen wusste und sich dann weinend unter die Bettdecke gelegt hat. Was ich verstehe, weil Fledermäuse ist ein zu wäre mir jetzt zu exotischer Gegner. Also mit Motten kann ich es aufnehmen. Heiß nicht, dass es gewinne. Fledermäuse auch, die sehen nichts, haben ihr Sonar-System. Soll ich laut quieken, soll ich die verwirren, mache ich mich dadurch noch auffälliger. Und ich habe mich auch sehr gewundert, wie sich so die Fledermäuse orientieren. Weil für mich im Kopf sind das schon schlaue Wesen, die, man sagt mir auch in der Mythologie viel nach und viel Cleverness nach, die ganze Vampire, Mythologie, ja Vampire, das ist schon ein bisschen was anderes, aber gut, okay, okay, gut, das erengst du dich an dem Vorder, aber weißt du, das ist schon interessant, die sagt man viel nach, so Fledermäusen, und deswegen dachte ich, die alle sind ein bisschen clever, die haben ja auch diese Ultraschall als Bewegungsform und checken dadurch Entfernungen und so und ihre Orientierung. Die sehen ja quasi mehr durch diese Schreierei als durch alles andere.
Und diese Federmaus ist wohl unglaublich laut schreiend durch die Wohnung geflattert, hat also die ganze Zeit geschrien und ist immer gegen Wände geflogen. Heisst ja umkehrschluss, dass es nicht die beste Art ist, also von Mutter Natur, zu einer Fledermaus. Seid nicht für so eine Einzimmerwohnung gedacht, vielleicht eher für den Wald. Aber finde ich gut, mittlerweile ist sie auch unterwegs als dunkle Rächerin von Köln-Ehrenfeld und schnappt hier Verbrecher, ohne sie umzubringen. Also finde ich nicht schlecht. Woher kommt eigentlich diese Sache mit Fledermäuse saugen Blut? Weil auch so bei Pokémon oder so, auch Zubat Golbat haben auch diese Blutsaugerfähigkeiten. Und Vampire natürlich auch. Aber woher kommt das denn? Also warum saugen Fledermäuse Blut? Hat das denn irgendeinen reellen Hintergrund? Ja, Fledermäuse saugen Blut aus... Die haben ja nicht mal scharfe Zähne oder so, oder?
Jetzt magst du zu viel.
Jetzt mag ich zu viel?
Also ich glaube, ihr könnt es gerne im Reddit
beantworten, aber ich finde das schon merkwürdig.
Ja, tatsächlich. Du könntest aber nicht alle Aufgaben,
die wir auch haben als Moderatoren
dieses Podcast. Nee, Recherche, nee, nee, nee, ich sag nicht,
macht eure eigene Anmoderation, aber
tatsächlich, ich glaube, in Australien oder so wurde jetzt auch die Fledermaus zum Vogel des Jahres gekürt, wo ich erstmal sage, Punkt eins ist kein Vogel, Punkt zwei, wegen der haben wir fucking Corona! Wie könnt ihr denn die zum Vogel des Jahres machen? Nee, wegen einer satten Leistung. Das war auch, glaube ich, die... Das ist eine satte Leistung. Das war, glaube ich, auch die Begründung der Jury. Satte Leistung, Hut ab. Muss man erst mal hinkriegen, sagte die Jury mit Tränen in den Augen. Das finde ich eine absolute Frechheit. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall mysteriöse Wesen, auch durch diese Nachtaktivität. Vampirfledermäuse, die gibt es nämlich, das ist die Vampirfledermaus, die heißt Desmodonitinä.
So, und die hat, siehst du hier, Zähnchen, kleine Zähnchen.
Ja, aber so groß sind die auch nicht.
Vampirfledermäuse sind die einzigen Säugetiere, deren Ernährung ausschließlich auf Blut basiert.
What?
Ihre nächsten Verwandten, die Blattnasenfledermäuse.
Blatt oder Blatt?
Blattnasen, weniger cool, ernähren sich von Insekten oder von Früchten. Ernähren sich sehr gesund von Früchten. Bei der Gemeinden Vampirfledermaus dienen Säugetiere als blutspendende Beute. Der Kammzahnvampir nutzt hingegen ausschließlich Vögel als Nahrungsquelle. Weissflügelvampire bevorzugen Vogelblut, können sich jedoch auch von dem der Säugetiere ernähren. Um nicht zu verhungern, brauchen sie spätestens alle drei Tage eine Blutmahlzeit, entweder von einem Beutetier oder als Spende von einem Artgenossen.
Also auch hier kann Blut reingekotzt werden.
Die beissen sich dann gegenseitig oder was?
Nee, ich glaube, die spucken sich gegenseitig Blut in den Mund.
Das ist ja abgefahren. Aber töten die die ihre Opfer dann auch oder saugen die den nur so hundert Milliliter ab und gehen dann wieder weg? Genau, saugen unbemerkt nachts ein bisschen was raus. Aber Theresa ist auch blass geworden, muss man auch sagen. Aber was ist, wenn der Mensch Blut trinkt? Also hat Blut Kalorien selbst? Also die müssen ja irgendwelche Nährstoffe davon bekommen, oder nicht? Er wird nicht auch fett und so ist er auch im Blut teilweise. Es gibt ja fettes Blut, sagt man ja bei Leuten, die fettes Blut haben zum Beispiel. Fettes Brot gibt es auch. Also ja, okay, finde ich spannend, aber könnte der Mensch vielleicht auch. Aber was heißt Saugen? Aber die saugen das nicht durch ihre Zähne, die haben nicht hohle Zähne, oder? Weil das ärgert mich nämlich immer bei Vampiren oder so, dass wenn du beim Vampir beißt, dann sein Opfer in den Nacken und übrig bleiben nur diese Punkte von den Zähnen. Ja, aber Vampire saugen durch die Zähne. Ja, aber wie das denn? Ja, naja. Ich dachte, die beißen da so ein Loch rein und saugen dann und nuckeln dann so da rum. So machen es, glaube ich, die Tiere. Mit Hilfe von wärmeempfindlichen Sensoren suchen die Tiere gezielt nach den Venen unter der Haut ihrer Opfer.
Nach dem Abschlecken der ausgesuchten Körperstelle, der Speichel enthält ein Betäubungsmittel,
werden Haare oder Federn entfernt.
Dann beißen sie mit den scharfen Ecken und Schneidezählen ein Stück der Haut heraus und lecken das Blut auf oder saugen es durch die Rillen an der Unterseite der Zunge. Du hast also recht, es wird bei den Tieren nicht durch die Zähne gezogen. Das denke ich mir nämlich auch immer. Jeder Vampirfilm macht das falsch, dass er impliziert, dass die durch die Zähne saugen, was überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt, wie so ein Strohhalm. Vampire sind ja ein Machwerk unserer Imagination. Ja, trotzdem würde ich gerne Medien konsumieren, die sich da auch Gedanken machen, wie das genau aussieht. Ich glaube, auch so Twilight und so hat sich auch keine Gedanken gemacht, ob sie dann noch so einen Rüssel haben. Das mit der Zunge finde ich ja gar nicht so schlecht. Du könntest ja sagen, man beisst so ein Loch rein und steckt dann so eine Rüsselzunge rein und darüber saugt man das dann so durch. Wie so ein Moskito. Genau, wie ein Moskito. Die haben ja auch einen Rüssel. Die machen Rüssel, ja. So, das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Also du willst Edward so einen Rüssel geben. Ja. Er ist nicht ein Klassischer. Ich denke da an einen Zungenrüssel, ich denke an einen Züssel, dass du halt einfach so einen Zuzelzüssel hast. Edward und Jacob haben beide so einen hotten Zungenrüssel. Jacob ist kein Vampir. Aber ich glaube, da kann man da noch ein bisschen was dran arbeiten. Aber die können sich ja auch nicht in Fledermäuse verwandeln. Also die sind, glaube ich, anders, auch die Twilight-Vampire. Die sind eh, das ist eine andere Richtung, eine andere Interpretation. Was ist die beste Vampirinterpretation? Graf Zahl. Graf Zahl in meinen Augen, wo auch,, habe ich das Gefühl, selten wirklich thematisiert wird, dass er ein Vampir ist. Er ist einfach ein Graf, was sich schon mal ganz gut fühlt. Natürlich im Englischen genial, Count, der zählt, Count, großartig. Daher kommt ja die Idee, dass er zählt. Ja, aber trotzdem, der Gag ist trotzdem gut. Nee, im Deutschen. Das muss man trotzdem erst mal draufkommen. Graf Zahl, Count, kannst du auch nichts anderes machen.
Im Deutschen macht es halt keinen Sinn, dass da ein Vampir ist, der zählt.
Also im amerikanischen ...
Das meine ich ja, im Englischen macht es auch keinen Sinn, dass er ein Vampir ist.
Nur weil er ein Graf ist, ist er nicht automatisch ein Vampir.
Nee, Grafen sind Vampir.
Nein.
Nee, da hast du jetzt ... Count Doku ist auch ein Vampir.
Das wird halt nicht thematisiert, weil es spannendere Sachen in seinem Leben zu erzählen gibt.
Er ist auch ein fantastischer Ska-Musiker, aber das kommt halt selten vor.
Das kommt halt nicht vor.
Weil es so viele andere Sachen zu erzählen gibt.
Weil andere Sachen los sind.
In den Comics wird das thematisiert.
Wir haben auch nie was von dem Gärtner-Hobby von Imperator Perpetin gehört.
Nein!
Einfach weil es irrelevant ist.
Vielleicht im Extended Universe, wer weiss.
Ja!
Aber das, nein, also das finde ich jetzt albern zu sagen, jeder Graf ist ein Vampir.
Es gibt erstens auch Vampirherzöge und zweitens ist auch nicht jeder ein Graf ein Vampir.
Aber es wird einfach so dargestellt.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob der jemals andere Muppets bei ist oder so, der Graf Zahl.
Oder ob das einfach so... Wie saug Graf Zahl den anderen Muppets Blut aus? Der saug dann diese Watte aus, die da drin ist in den Muppets. Ich glaube, die bluten nicht, oder? Gibt es eine Szene, wo Muppets bluten? Ich glaube nicht, nein. Kann schon sein. Ich bin aber auch nicht so tief im Muppetverse drin. Ich habe mir letztens, wollte ich einen Muppet-Film angucken, aber ich glaube, ich bin zu spät eingestiegen. Das war bei mir Film acht oder so und ich habe nichts verstanden, irgendwie so ein besprechender Frosch, da komme ich irgendwie nicht rein. Deswegen denke ich, fange ich jetzt erstmal wieder von ganz von vorne an. Ich habe auch irgendwie das Gefühl, dass Peanuts und Muppets zusammengehören, aber ich weiß nicht warum, dass die so ineinander übergehen und dass die dann sozusagen Muppets sind in der Fantasie von Charlie Brown. So irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dass manche Universen eher zusammenhängen als andere. Und das ist der Junge, der auch Star Express sich vorstellt macht. Es hängt auch alles im gleichen weirden Spielzeuguniversum, genau wie Toy Story auch. Es ist alles eins. Und der macht auch diese Pinguine, die leben auch in derselben Welt, aber auf der anderen Seite der Erde. Aber es ist dieselbe Welt, aber die haben sich noch nie getroffen. Charlie Brown war noch nie in der Antarktis. Falls doch, schreibt es ins Reddit, schickt uns ein Bild, wie der mit seiner ... Most boring Reddit, wird das auch. Es wird das seltsamste Reddit. Warum ich aber erzählen wollte, dass es in meinen Sicherungskasten läuft, weil ich nämlich, wie ich behaupte, dass der Vater von Matze auch im Start war, mich die ganze Zeit dann so durchbullshitte. Weil natürlich kam dann der Handwerker und der war dann die ganze Nacht bei mir
und weil er
diesen Sicherungskasten wieder an den Start bringen wollte
und hat mir dann noch nachts
Strom besorgt und hat einen
Sicherungskasten neu gebaut.
Und da habe ich, glaube ich,
dann dachte am Ende, dass ich so eine Art
Abschluss, so ein Elektromeister
bin oder sowas, weil ich die ganze
Zeit Ja gesagt habe,
als würde ich alles verstehen, was er sagt und so.
Weil ich nicht, ich habe das nicht in mir,
dass ich Leuten eingestehen kann, dass ich
Dinge nicht weiß oder sowas.
Ich lüge viel.
Ja, vor allem, du willst ja auch den Flow nicht aufhalten.
Du willst ja auch nicht sagen, ja, jetzt muss ich den Gleichstrom
hier anschliessen, damit die Voltzahl steigt
und du sagst, schön, können Sie mir das bitte noch mal genauer erklären? Bevor Sie das machen, erklären Sie mir das bitte noch mal in Ruhe anhand dieser Zeichnung. Nee, genau, man will bei der Elektrizität, generell wenn es um Elektronik geht, willst du den Flow nicht unterbrechen. Ja, absolut. Stark. Ja, aber wie, also angenommen, jetzt fragt dich jemand, erzählt von einem Film. Ja, wie in Citizen Kane diese Szene, hast du ja gesehen, ne? Ja, ja. Wie oft? oft jedes Mal, wie oft lügst du, wenn du es nicht gesehen hast? Jedes Mal. Nein, ich finde, es ist auch eine Höflichkeitslüge, weil dann zu sagen nein, dann hältst du den, stellst du dem anderen Bein, das ist ein rhetorisches Bein, wo der sagt so, ach so, ja, dann musst du den wieder nochmal ausholen und dann merkt die Person auch, so interessant ist meine Beobachtung nicht, dass ich jetzt den gesamten Film noch mal nacherzähle. Lass denen einfach seine Beobachtung sagen,
die checkt man in der Regel auch, ohne den Film gesehen zu haben.
Ich verstehe genau diesen Punkt, aber wie oft lügst du?
Weil ich mache es wirklich nicht zu 100 Prozent.
Es kommt,
gerade wenn es ein Gespräch über Filme ist,
will ich mir
manchmal die Blödsinn nicht geben,
ich will aber auch nicht so tun, als hätte ich alles gesehen.
Ich will ein Bild,
was meines Erachtens mein Filmwissen repräsentiert. Also lüge ich in 70 Prozent der Fälle. Weil du 30 Prozent der Filme gesehen hast. Ja, okay. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich meine, auch zur Not immer Letterbox in der Hinterhand haben. Da habe ich alle Filme markiert, die ich gesehen habe. Schaut da gerne nach, bevor ihr mit mir redet, und dann wisst ihr, womit ihr es zu tun habt. Was sind deine Most Lightabout-Filme? Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, die Indiana-Jones-Trilogie. Hast du nicht gesehen? Doch, doch, klar, aber halt nicht den vierten. Und auch dann so Der Pater und so habe ich den ersten gesehen, das ist auch schon lange her, wirklich so ein paar Klassiker, so Casablanca und so, da schwimme ich schon manchmal so im Prinzip. Bei mir ist Most Lightabout, war lange nach der Kanone, bis ich es gesehen habe. Wie oft redest du da drüber? Naja, im Neonier-Magazin-Autorenraum war das auf jeden Fall der Most Lightabout-Film meinerseits. Hotshots ist Most Lightabout. Oh ja. Ace Ventura. Oh, okay. Ja, genau. Und Citizen Kane ist auf jeden Fall auch ganz weit oben. Klar, niemand hat den Film gesehen.
Der hat irgendwie 30 Euro eingespielt, aber jeder
hat ihn gesehen. Aber ich rede ständig darüber. Aber ich habe das Gefühl,
bei manchen Filmen hat man auch schon so viele Clips
und Gifs gesehen, dass es eigentlich reicht, den gesehen
zu haben. Wenn man das so zusammenstückeln würde,
hätte ich bestimmt schon 60 Prozent des Films
gesehen. Ja, ja, glaube ich auch.
Man täuscht sich, man täuscht sich manchmal.
Manchmal ist der Film auch länger, als man denkt. Und falls ihr euch
einen Film angucken wollt, dann geht einfach mal auf daspodcastufo.de und bestellt euch schöne Tüte Popcorn und ein bisschen Nacho. Könnt ihr einfach mal schön vorbeigebracht bekommen. Ich finde die Idee fantastisch. Wir haben alle verschiedene Sorten Nachos, wir haben alles verschieden. Ihr könnt genau eingeben, ich hätte gern gemischtes Popcorn, zu so viel Prozent das, zu so viel Prozent das. Ihr könnt die verrücktesten Forderungen reinschreiben.
Der Schieberegler funktioniert gerade nicht.
Wir müssen uns nochmal anrufen und erstmal sagen, wie viel Prozent.
Einfach in die Kommentarspalte dazuschreiben.
Ist immer bei jedem Kommentar dabei.
Und dann ist es richtig cool und dann vor allem, ich habe
manchmal das Gefühl im Kino, weil du hast es ja mit
echten Menschen zu tun und es gibt ein
klaren Protokoll. Du willst nicht sagen,
ja, ich hätte gerne die Nachos mit Käsesauce, aber
machen wir mal so die vierfache Menge Käsesauce drauf. Bei der Bestellformular kannst Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das schon mit dabei. So ein Smiley kommt zurück, so ein Augenrollsmiley. Und auch ganz viele Nachfragen, wollen sie wirklich viermal Käse haben? Ist das dein scheiß Ernst, du Fettsack, sowas? Ihnen ist schon klar, dass es insgesamt neuntausend Kalorien hat. Ja, weiß ich. Wurde es halt auch so andrücken und nochmal abhaken. Zehn Sekunden warten. Aber jetzt war meine Idee, weil ich bin ja ein fortschrittlicher Denker. Stark. Deswegen habe ich überlegt, Netflix hat ja auch als DVD-Versand begonnen. Ja. Und ist mittlerweile ein Streaming-Anbieter. Wollen wir nicht diesen Snack-Versand direkt überspringen, diesen Schritt? Ja, also wir machen ja auch kein Geld mit den Snacks. Also die Snacks, da machen wir ja Verlust. Nee, nee, wir würden Geld damit machen, dass man uns anruft und mit dem Anrufen verdienen wir mehr Geld. Genau, die Hotline ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr teuer und die Idee ist auch, dass wir absichtlich die Sachen zu spät liefern, damit die Leute anrufen und darüber verdienen wir eigentlich unsere Geld. Genau, und wir würden auch versuchen, euch lange in der Haltung zu halten. Wir stellen sehr viele Rückfragen und werden irgendwann privat. Haben Sie wirklich acht Portionen Käsesosse bestellt? Soll ich Ihnen das mal kurz ausrechnen, was das an Kalorien ist? 480 pro Töpfchen Käse mal 7. Auf der Website steht kein Judgment. Das ist über dem Tagesbedarf eines erwachsenen Menschen.
Auf der Website steht kein Judgment.
Ja, das gilt nicht für die Hotline, das steht extra explizit dabei.
Die Hotline wird hart gejudged.
Da wird richtig hart gejudged.
Nee, das finde ich wichtig.
Das finde ich wichtig, dass man da auch anonym alles bestellen kann.
Der Trend geht eh dahin.
Ich glaube, in Zukunft werden Menschen ihr Haus nicht mehr verlassen
und dann auch nicht mehr ins Kino gehen.
Aber ich glaube, wie gesagt, dass die Kinolobby dahintersteht.
Irgendjemand ist da, ist da dahinter.
Irgend so ein Projektor oder
irgendwie sowas. Hat da was dagegen?
Einen so einen Projektor? Ja, einen so einen Projektormeister,
der da irgendwie alle Filme jongliert und in der Hand hat.
Der hat da was dagegen, dass du,
ich glaube nicht, weil, und
wir können ja auch einen Netflix ins Boot holen einfach, ne?
Das quasi neben dem Film-Ding so gibt es einen Button, wo du deine typische Snacks einfach direkt einbinden kannst. So ein Popcorn-Symbol. Ja. Oder dass du sozusagen, wenn du bingest, kriegst du alle fünf Folgen eine neue Lieferung Popcorn. So automatisch. Und du kannst es, weil Netflix weiss ja, wie lange die Folgen sind, und dann kann man es genau so timen, dass genau zwischen zwei Folgen vor dem Finale dann nochmal die Popcornlieferung ankommt.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Das wäre doch geil.
Super, Movie Snacks.
Ja, die automatisiert dann kommen.
Vor allem, das ist vielleicht tatsächlich gar nicht so dumm, wenn du sagst, du bezahlst nicht pro Lieferung, sondern du hast ein Abo.
Und du kannst so viel bestellen, wie du willst, weil Popcorn kostet ja quasi gar nichts. Das ist ja Zucker und diese Maiskörner, die sind ja nahezu wertlos. Das heißt, wenn du wirklich sagst, du zahlst irgendwie 30 Euro im Monat und darfst, was bestellst du? Softdrinks nahezu wertlos, Popcorn nahezu wertlos, Nachos weiß ich nicht. Ich verstehe generell nicht, weil der Trend geht ja in allen Bereichen zu Abos. Wir sind jetzt bei Musikabos, war auch undenkbar noch vor ein paar Jahren und so. Wir haben Filmabos, wir haben Abos.
Vor bestimmt fünf Jahren habe ich das Kino-Abo gecallt, dass man quasi einen monatlichen Beitrag bezahlt und dann dafür so oft ins Kino gehen kann, wie man will.
Ich wurde eines Besseren belehrt, weil neulich war ich dann im Kino mit einem Kumpel in French Dispatch und der hatte so eine Karte von diesem Kino und bezahlt monatlich und kann so oft reingehen, wie er will. Und da habe ich gesagt, das war meine Idee von fünf Jahren. Er meinte, das gibt es seit 20 Jahren. Von daher, okay, habe ich mich einfach gelogen. Ich meine, du hast letzte Woche auch den Toaster erfunden, Glückwunsch dazu. Und Ebay. Und Ebay und X-Hamster, aber da muss ich dich leider auch enttäuschen, das gibt's schon.
Ja, ja, klar. Great minds think alike.
Ich glaub, das ist nicht so dumm,
weil wie viel Popcorn kannst du wirklich
essen, also da müsste man halt
irgendein kluger BWLer das mal ausrechnen,
wie viel jemand wirklich bestellen müsste,
auch wenn eine ganze WG so ein
Account hat, aber ich glaube, Popcorn ist so billig,
das reicht. Du musst vielleicht dann
auch die Lieferkosten nicht.
Du hast dann auch so das mit dem Drohnensystem
Vielen Dank. Auch wenn eine ganze WG so ein Account hat, aber ich glaube, Popcorn ist so billig, das reicht. Du musst vielleicht dann auch die Lieferkosten nicht. Du hast dann auch das mit dem Drohnen-System oder so, oder du hast so wie so eine Art Streife. Du hast so Lieferanten, die immer unterwegs sind und die immer so ein bisschen Popcorn. So ein Drohnensystem gesagt? Ja, aber du hast halt so eine Art Lieferbus, der durch die Stadt fährt, der immer heiße Popcorn hier im Kofferraum hat. Wie diese Zement, die quasi während der Fahrt machen die Popcorn. Wenn die vorbeifahren, ist es immens laut, weil drinnen wird Popcorn erzeugt, das macht so. Und der Fahrer hat dann die App, die immer anzeigt, oh, hier ist Alarm, hier will jemand Popcorn, fährt da direkt hin, gibt die Tüte raus. Wollen wir das nicht verbinden mit der GTA-Idee? Weil bei GTA, was habe ich am liebsten gemacht? Habe ich die Story gespielt und Leute umgebracht? Nein. Habe ich am liebsten Taxi gespielt? Ja. Jeder Mensch, These, will Taxi spielen, eigentlich auch. Ich hätte auch Bock, ist halt das Problem wegen Personenbeförderungsgesetz, shit. Verdammtes Personenbeförderungsgesetz. Aber einigem, du hast abends mal eine Stunde Zeit.
Dann darfst du nämlich,
und jetzt merchen wir zwei Ideen, die auf der Oberfläche nicht zusammenpassen,
darfst du dich in das Popcornmobil
setzen und quasi
kriegst du kannst unsere
Nein, du setzt sie in dein Auto, das meine ich damit.
Ich sollte keine Metaphern benutzen, weil sonst wird es unübersichtlich.
Also du gehst in dein Auto
Im Spiel oder in echt? In echt jetzt! Okay. Und fährst zu unserem Popcorn-Fabrik. Ja. So, und dann kannst du halt die freie Zeit, die du hast, kannst du dir ein bisschen Geld dazu verdienen, indem du dann für uns Popcorn und Snacks verteilst. Das kann jeder machen. Ja. Und pro Lieferung kriegst du so eine GTA-artige Karte, wo oben so ein Punkt ist, wo die nächsten Leute sind. Verstehe, und dadurch kannst du sozusagen, also es gibt zwei Arten, entweder du hast Abo oder du bist Fahrer. Und dann kannst du sozusagen dein Abo dir selber verdienen, indem du selber Popcorn ausfährst. Es gibt natürlich auch ein Drive-in, du kannst natürlich auch schön, also es gibt dann so Filialen in der Stadt, wo überall riesige Popcorn-Tüten sind, wo du auch einfach reinfahren kannst und sagst, machen Sie mir den Kofferraum voll. Und dann kommt so eine Mitarbeiterin raus mit so einem riesigen Schlauch, die einfach den Kofferraum aufmacht und einfach das Popcorn da reinballert und Kofferraum zu und dann wirst du nach Hause geschickt. Ich glaube, das funktioniert richtig gut. Ich glaube, das kann funktionieren. Ich glaube, nach einer Woche will die ganze Stadt keinen Popcorn mehr sehen und eine gesamte Stadt ist einfach überfressende von Popcorn. Ich will ja vor allem amerikanische Snackkultur herbringen. Also wir haben auch Pretzelbites, Mini-Hotdogs, Mini-Hotdogs, Russe Hotdogs, Corndogs, Riesen-Hotdogs, Frikandellen. Ja, herrlich, schön. Oder auch mal sowas wie Austern. Also auch mal wirklich die High-Society-Class-Kino mitnehmen. Wenn es mal ein französischer Arthouse-Film sein darf. Ja, das ist natürlich auch geil. Du kannst Snack-Pakete passend zu Filmen anbieten. Das finde ich jetzt super, wenn man sagt, ich gucke die Folge Seinfeld mit dem Soup-Nazi, kriegst du eine richtig geile Suppe. Oh, ist ja eine richtig schöne French-Onion French Onion Suppe mit Käse drin und sowas.
Perfekt.
Aber da kann man mit Netflix kooperieren, dass du quasi zum richtigen Film die richtigen Menüs bekommst. Genau, schaust du irgendwie Moana an und dann hast du so ein hawaiianisches, tropisches Fruchtcocktail-Angebot, irgendwie mit Ananas und so mit so einem coolen Cocktail. Perfekt. Habe ich dieses Jahr zu Dinner for One gemacht. Da gibt es ja wirklich letztes zum Silvester, da hatte ich am Ende ein Dinner vorbereitet, wo es quasi alle Dinner for One-Gänge gab. Und der passenden Begleitung dazu, Getränken. Quasi wie in dem Sketch gab es genau diese Sachen. Das ist natürlich geil. Das kann man natürlich auch denken, dass man dann bei manchen ausgewählten neuen Squid Game zum Beispiel. Ja, es gibt den Fischringe. Ja, oder diese eklige Essen, was die die ganze Zeit essen. Habe ich noch nicht gesehen, leider. Dieses pappige. Habe ich leider noch nicht gesehen. Naja, gut, wir können trotzdem drüber reden. Ich habe leider die Serie nicht gesehen. Ja, okay. Tut mir leid. Ist nicht so schlimm. Da sind die gefangen in so einer großen Lagerhalle und essen halt so pappiges, oft Gefängnisessen. Ich weiß nicht, du kannst damit nichts anfangen, die Information gerade, weil du die Serie nicht gesehen hast, aber es ist kein Problem. Und das können wir zum Beispiel auch einfach mit Kredenzen. Finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Ich glaube, Essen auf Abo ist ohnehin eine gute Idee. Du sagst eh schon, alles trennet gerade zum Abo. Und natürlich ... Wo sind die Friseure die ersten Friseure? Ich zeige mir ordentlich einen Beitrag. Man kann so oft kommen, wie man will. Du kannst jederzeit hingehen, wo du willst. Die haben eine Kartei, wo auch genau drinsteht, welche Haare du hast, wie viel du beim letzten Mal geschnitten bekommen hast. Hä, das ist eine ganz andere Idee. Das verstehe ich jetzt gar nicht. Nein, wenn die dein Abo haben, wenn du einen Account bei denen hast, dann brauchst du dein Abo und Account, dann merken die sich auch, was du wann geschnitten hast und dann ja, ich würde gerne wieder so aussehen wie da. Ich verstehe nicht, der Trend geht doch eh zu Abos. Ja, eben und ich glaube auch bei Podcasts. Denn wir haben was Fantastisches für euch vorbereitet. Du Genie. Denn wie ihr wahrscheinlich mitbekommen habt und wahrscheinlich jede Folge an dieser fucking Gitarre ablesen könnt, machen wir seit einiger Zeit Werbung. Und wir haben uns überlegt, Mensch, gibt es da nicht noch eine bessere Lösung dafür? Und jetzt haben wir nach langem hin und her tatsächlich uns dazu entschlossen, einen Club aufzumachen. Genau. Wir machen einen Club auf, den Ufo Club. Ab sofort gibt es den Ufo Club. Ab sofort gibt es ihn, dem könnt ihr beitreten und ab dann bekommt ihr einen exklusiven, persönlichen Feed ohne Werbung. Ihr könnt das Podcast UFO anhören, ohne Werbung, alle Folgen sind in diesem Feed drin, könnt ihr immer schon anhören und auch einen Tag früher, also die neue Folge kommt immer schon freitags und nicht samstags, einen Tag früher und ohne Werbung, wenn ihr uns bei Patreon unterstützt und Teil im UFO-Club werdet. Genau, und wenn das noch nicht reicht, bekommt ihr, wenn ihr UFO-Club-Mitglieder seid, kriegt ihr auch noch 10% Merch-Rabatt. Was, Merch-Rabatt? Kann man denn wieder Merch kaufen? Ja, dank unseres umfassenden UFO-Relaunches, auf den wir uns sehr freuen, gibt es neuen Merch mit einem ganz, ganz besonderen Künstler, der uns selber unterstützt hat. Nämlich hatten mal wieder Hilfe von dem fantastischen Christoph Niemann, dem großen Illustrator, dem beliebsten Illustratoren-Grafiker auf der Welt, macht viel für den New Yorker zum Beispiel und hat eben auch das neue UFO-Logo designt, das neue Emblem, unser neues UFO ist von Christoph Niemann. Endlich müssen wir nicht mehr Keith Haring sein Design klauen, sondern wir können es Christoph Niemann klauen mit seinem Wissen. Genau, und er hat uns sogar noch schöne Entwürfe gemacht, die wir jetzt auf Shirts und Hoodies drucken für euch. Also es gibt halt einen tollen Merch-Drop und da kriegt ihr alle Informationen auf unseren Social-Media-Kanälen und es gibt auch noch Shirts, die ihr immer kaufen könnt, wie ihr das bislang auch schon kennt. Also, es wird einen umfassenden Reout geben, Redesign, neues Merch, es gibt den UFO-Club, den könnt ihr auf patreon.com abschliessen. patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO und schaut mal bei unserem Shop vorbei, da seht ihr, welche T-Shirts ihr immer bekommt, welche Teile des Drops sind, also da werden dann auch nur so viele hergestellt, wie bestellt wurden im Vorhinein, da steht da aber alles schaut bei Social Media vorbei und werdet Teil des UFO-Clubs, damit ihr vielleicht auch mal Teil eines exklusiven Clubs seid, ein besonderer Club. Genau, wir würden uns auf jeden Fall sehr über Unterstützung da freuen, das Ganze kostet 5 Dollar im Monat und ist auf Patreon abschliessbar. Ja, macht das, falls ihr keinen Bock mehr habt auf Werbung, ist das eine gute Alternative. Aber natürlich auch gesagt, für alle, die da keine Lust drauf haben, ändert sich gar nichts. Die Folgen kommen weiterhin ganz normal, dann aber eben mit Werbung hier und da. Also könnt ihr alles selber entscheiden, wie ihr das machen wollt. Wir freuen uns natürlich über jeden, der zu uns in unser Baumhaus kommt, in unseren Club und der sich an den Clubtisch sitzt. Und ja, schaut mal vorbei, ob das was für euch ist. Genau, und dann haben wir jetzt auch bald eine neue Website, freue mich auch schon sehr drauf, da ist alles auch nochmal übersichtlich gestaltet und nochmal zum neuen Logo, wir haben uns wirklich mit Christoph Niemann was ganz Besonderes ausgedacht, nämlich das neue Logo ist veränderbar und auch von euch veränderbar. Wir freuen uns darüber sehr. Diese Idee kann man sich vorstellen, ein bisschen wie das alte MTV-Logo, was sich immer verändert hat. Also wenn ihr Grafiker, Grafikerinnen seid oder einfach mal Bock habt, euch ein bisschen selbstverwirklichen, dann bieten wir die Datei auch als Download auf unserer Website an, auf unserer neuen. Alle Infos findet ihr dazu auch nochmal auf unseren Social-Media-Kanälen. Und dann könnt ihr euch ein euch ein bisschen selbstverständlicher mit unserem Ufo rumspielen. Und wer weiß, vielleicht ändern wir das auch mal. Und es gibt mal vielleicht andere Logos, andere Designs. Also das ist sehr spannend, was wir da vorhaben durch. Wir sind sehr gespannt, was da alles von euch kommt. Wir haben ja schon viele fantastische Intros bekommen von euch. Jetzt schauen wir mal, was ihr auf der grafischen Seite drauf habt. Genau, zu den Intros, also wenn noch ein paar Musiker unter euch sind, würden wir uns auf jeden Fall sehr über neue, heiße Intros freuen. Wir freuen uns über alles, solange es gerne kurz ist, aber auch da freuen wir uns weiterhin über alle Intros und natürlich auch über das Intro der heutigen Folge, glaube ich, haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt, dass da kam scroll scroll scroll dass von Kasi kam, vielen Dank an Kasi für dieses fantastische Intro, für diese heutige Folge. Kasi? Ja. Kurz von Kasi mir. Kann gut sein, ich weiss es nicht, aber als Kasi mir würdest du dich nicht nicht Mirisimi nennen oder sowas? Siri? Kann auch sein. Steht Siri kurz für Kasirini? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Bin mir nicht so sicher. Ja, also macht das, schaut mal vorbei und wir sind gespannt auf was alles kommt. Pufo 2.0 startet, wir heben ab, wir haben nochmal ein extra Triebwerk unten dran bekommen.
Genau, wird alles ein bisschen cooler, ein bisschen moderner, ein bisschen schicker.
Gutes Timing auch, weil letzte Woche hat tatsächlich uns jemand geschrieben, Herr, eure Website ist hässlich. Und da dachte ich mir, tja, wenn du wüsstest, dass wir bald eine richtig neue, coole Website bekommen, und dann kannst du deinen Scheisskommentar auch wieder hier zurücknehmen. Macht ihr das manchmal auch da draußen, dass wenn ihr Unrecht hattet, einmal was löscht? Das finde ich immer spannend, dass Leute das nicht machen, aber es scheint tatsächlich nicht so gängig zu sein. Du ja auch nicht. Ja, doch, also wenn ich wirklich komplett falsch liege, wenn ich Leute komplett verwechsel und Leuten schreibe und eigentlich jemand andener meinte, und dann glaube ich, lösche ich das schon im Nachhinein. Aber ich meine, wir sind ja eh Tweetlöscher, das ist ja eh gängig. Ich glaube, ich habe in meinem Leben mehr Tweets gelöscht, als ich geschrieben habe. Da ist das völlig normal und das auch aus gutem Grund. Definitiv. Ja, ein bisschen habe ich das Twitter-Mojo verloren, also dafür, dass die ersten Folgen dieses Podcasts ausschließlich daraus bestanden, wie wir uns Twitter-Gags überlegt haben und live verfolgt haben, wie viele Sterne sie haben damals. Sterne, ja. Schlecht gealtert alles. Ja, das stimmt. Aber eine schöne Zeit. Aber wir können Twitter auch mal anderen Leuten überlassen. Da machen auch andere Leute tolle Sachen. Ja, ich wüsste es nicht, wer, aber ja. Findet man bestimmt, findet man bestimmt auch auf jeden Fall. Nee, wir machen andere Projekte. Du hast ja mittlerweile dein Buchprojekt angekündigt. Du bist dabei zu schreiben, habe ich gehört, unter falschem Namen.
Ich habe genau, habe ich dem Vertrauen erzählt, dass ich unter dem falschen Namen anfange, Sachbücher zu schreiben. Das heißt, jedes Buch, das jetzt rauskommt, könnte aus der Feder von Stefan Tietze stammen. Ihr könnt ja gerne mal auf Reddit schreiben, bei welchen Büchern ihr denkt, dass es eigentlich Stefan Tietze sein könnte. Weil das Ding ist ja, also ich bin schon sehr
darauf bedacht, so dass die Sachen, die ich mache,
die ich von mir raushaue,
dass die stilistisch einigermaßen passen
und ich dahinter stehe.
So, und jetzt ist natürlich das Problem
klar, man muss sich
besorgen, muss gucken, was man macht.
Und deswegen dachte ich, Ghostwriter
oder mal so eine Folge
Wapo Bodensee
oder mal
Es ist ein wieder ein bisschen zu pushen, wäre so die große Buch-Schnitzeljagd. Zu sagen, keine Ahnung, irgendeine super krass berühmte Person, sagen wir mal, Kanye West hat ein Buch geschrieben unter falschem Namen, das kommt in den nächsten zwei Monaten raus, wir sagen aber nicht welches. Schaut mal, ob ihr es findet. Und dann müssen ja die ganzen Fans alle Bücher kaufen, die rauskommen in der Zeit, die aufmerksam lesen und sagen, könnte das von meinem Idol sein, ja oder nein, dann gibt es ein Forum, dann gibt es irgendwie Abstimmungen, dann gibt es einen extra Podcast dazu, wo die Bücher alle analysiert werden, die alle gekauft werden müssen. Das könnte, glaube ich, nochmal einen Riesen-Push geben. Was ich auch spannend finde, gerade mit Twitter, wenn wir jetzt einen Account anlegen würden, neuen Account und den mit Gags füttern würden,
würde der auch,
würde der früher oder später vielleicht so viele Follower haben wie wir.
Das ist schwierig. Aber das ist ein guter
Trick, um herauszufinden, ob man
zu Recht an dem Punkt ist, an dem man ist,
in Comedy Deutschland oder so.
Weil man theoretisch
müsste man ja auch quasi
den gleichen Erfolg rekreieren können mit den Tweets. Ich glaube nicht, aber ich glaube, da gibt es mittlerweile auch Programme und Algorithmen, die analysieren, die Stilanalysen machen und die Texte dann zuweisen können, wo dann irgendwann raussteht, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Martin Heidegger hat irgendwie ein Band von Lustiges Taschenbuch geschrieben, weil einfach der Stil so gut passt und man einfach da rückwirkend natürlich diese ganzen
Ghostwriter-Sachen total gut entlarven kann.
Unvergessen Albert Camus
Family Guy-Folge natürlich.
Ja, man kann sich da heute nicht mehr
davor verstecken, irgendwie
die ganzen verbotenen Liebefolgen von
Kant, also da kommt man heute raus,
die mussten auch Geld verdienen. Nur wenn man
heute sagt, das sind Genies irgendwie, die sind auf Geldscheinen, natürlich mussten die auch hier und da ihren Taler verdienen. Kann das auf Geld scheinen? Ich verrate nicht auf welchen. Weil er auch sein Gesicht geliehen hat. Ja, ein Facewriter, einfach so, ich leide mein Gesicht. Könntest du jetzt so aus dem Kopf so einen Fünfziger fälschen. Nein. Nein.
Ich war falsche Wort. Du meinst, ich gebe dir ein Blatt Papier
und du malst ein Fünfziger auf, oder was?
Oder was meinst du mit Fälschen?
Das Wort war ein bisschen irreführend.
Guck mal, das ist doch eine Sendung für Sat.1.
Nein.
Ralf Schmitz, hörst du zu?
Hörst du zu?
Wie findest du die Sendung?
Wie findest du die Sendung? Ha, ha, die Sendung, ha ha ha, ha ha ha. Da könnte man zum Beispiel machen, zehn Promis kriegen Blatt Papier, müssen da ein Fünfziger drauf malen, und dann gehen die alle zum Supermarkt, und wessen Fünfziger angenommen wird, gewinnt die Folge. Das ist eine geile Idee. Nein. Das ist eine geile Idee. Ich hasse alle Ideen, liebe Haben. Ich hasse die alle. Du hast wirklich die Popcorn-Snack-Idee? Nein, die mag ich. Die ist doch nicht schlecht. Wo sind die Investoren? Falls ihr Geld zu Hause rumliegen habt und denkt, was mache ich damit, das schrumpft jeden Tag, das schmilzt mir durch die Finger, dann gebt es lieber uns und wir investieren es und dann kriegt ihr eine Tüte Popcorn dafür. Das wäre jetzt die erste Idee seit langer Zeit mal wieder, wo ich sagen würde, die verdient den Namen das Podcast. Die verdient wirklich den Namen das Podcast-Ufo. Das finde ich sehr gut, wenn wir das umsetzen könnten. Das finde ich super. Moviesnacks sind perfekt, Moviesnacks. Ich meine, wie toll ist eine ist eine Popcornmaschine? Du hast eine große Küche, du setzt einfach ein paar Töpfe auf und dann kannst du Popcorn machen. Aber wie macht man denn salziges Popcorn eigentlich? Hm, was für eine geheime Zutat kommt da wohl zu. Ich meine, wie schaffst du es denn, wenn du jetzt einfach Popcorn machst und da Salz drüber streust, dann interessiert das ja das Popcorn nicht, das rieselt ja da einfach durch. Das Popcorn ist ja, ist Popcorn nicht Zucker, Mais und Fett und man kann das Zucker auch einfach gegen Salz tauschen? Ja, aber Zucker schmilzt ja, Salz doch nicht. Salz schmilzt bei 1000 Grad oder so. Warum muss es denn schmilzen? Ja, damit es anhaftet den Popcorn. Ich glaube, da reicht, wie gesagt, dieser butterige Fettaspekt
des Popcorns.
Aber ich glaube, das ist vielleicht so ganz fein
gemeint. Warum gibt es keinen Pudersalz eigentlich?
Oh, es gibt feines Salz, feines Salz.
Aber so fein wie Puderzucker.
Und ich glaube auch, dass Salz
sich auflöst, ehrlich gesagt.
Ein gutes Beispiel
wäre zum Beispiel Meerwasser.
Aha, geht weiter. Du hast meine Aufmerksamkeit. Ja, ich habe jetzt nicht mehr bringen wollen. Ich dachte, das hätte ich schon überzeugt, aber okay, dann reden wir doch weiter. Meersalz ist ja jetzt auch nicht in grossen Salzkörnern im Meer vertreten. Weiter. Du hast einfach Wasser. Weiter. Also, These, Salz löst sich in Wasser auf. Ich höre. Also auch am Popcorn. Mehr, mehr, gib mir mehr. Es kann sich am Popcorn festkrallen. Ich geniesse das gerade richtig. Ich geniesse das gerade richtig. Gebt mir mehr Wissen.
Also, okay, das kann ich verstehen, wenn du Salzwasser über die Popcorns sprenkelst, aber dann werden die Popcorns ja feucht und schlapp.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, ich kann mich nur noch an diesen einen legendären Satz erinnern,
den ich wahrscheinlich schon ein paar Mal gesagt habe, einfach weil er in meinem Erinnerung bleibt, wir haben ja alle Schulerpraktikum gemacht in der Schule
und dann kamen wir alle nach einer Woche
Schulerpraktikum zurück und sollten erzählen, was wir erlebt
haben. Und wir waren alle so, ja,
okay, keine Ahnung, aber eine Mitschülerin,
die war hyped, die hatte
weit aufgerissene Augen, hochroten Kopf,
die hat den
Gott gesehen, die hat die Nachwelt gesehen und die hatte ihr Praktikum im Kino. Ach so, im Kino. Und die hat erzählt, ey Leute, ihr glaubt nicht, was da passiert in der Popcornmaschine. Ich war einfach total, die hat einfach ihre Berufung gefunden. Das, was für ein Praktikum sein soll, die einfach gesagt, Leute, ich will im Popcorn leben, den Rest meines Lebens. Und die meinte, ja, du hast halt dann so eine Maschine und da tust du oben verschiedene Sachen rein zu dem Popcorn und dann wird entweder süsses oder salziges Popcorn gemacht. Bei süss haben wir dann so eine Mischung aus Zucker, das schmilzt dann so Karamell und für salziges Popcorn tun wir da eine Substanz rein, die ist salziger als Salz. Ja, aber warum hast du gerade gefragt, wie man das macht? Aber was war das? Ist das so eine Art Flüssigkeit oder so eine Art Essenz,
Salzessenz oder was auch immer?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das denn ist, aber es scheint ja,
ich weiß es nicht. Aber heißt,
wir sagen Salz zu etwas, was
gar nicht das Saldigste ist,
wohingegen wir sagen Zucker zu der
absolut richtigen, zu der absolut richtigen
Elemente. Das ist ja normal, es gibt ja auch Sachen, die
ananassiger sind als Ananas. Never.
Natürlich. Es gibt Dinge, die schmecken intensiver nach Ananas als Ananas selbst. Doch, na klar. Nein, auf jeden Fall nicht. Natürlich, du hast ja nicht. Unnatürlich, unnatürliches. Nee, nee, nee, du hast wirklich auch teilweise Früchte, die sind, die werden ja, das Problem ist ja, du schaust einmal in den Dschungel und sagst, ja hier Orange, Banane, Ananas, kein Problem. Ja, du hast die Big Five. Apfel, Birne, Ananas, Orange, Kirche.
Und alles andere wird quasi gesagt, das schmeckt wie Ananas,
aber ist jetzt so Papaya.
Und dann irgendwann hundert Jahre später dringen Forscher tiefer in den Urwald ein.
Wie in Indiana Jones 3, oder?
Ja, zum Beispiel, meine Lieblingsszene.
Und da findest du zum Beispiel eine Frucht, die noch ananassiger schmeckt als Ananas.
Aber jetzt nennst du ja die Ananas nicht um und nennst die irgendwie Marrone oder Mararelle oder was auch immer,
irgendeinen Name, und nennst die neue Frucht Ananas,
weil dann sind ja die Joghurts schon auf dem Markt.
So, und dann hast du ja ein Riesenproblem,
weil du dann nicht sagen kannst, das ist die noch ananassiger.
Das ist ein Vermarktungsproblem.
Das ist ein Benennungsproblem.
Das ist ein Benennungsvermarktungsproblem. Das ist 70% ein Vermarktungsproblem. Das ist ein Benennungsproblem. Das ist ein Benennungsvermarktungsproblem.
Es ist 70% ein Vermarktungsproblem, 30% ein Benennungsproblem, aber trotzdem hat es beide Komponenten das Problem. Das Problem hat beide Komponenten, da will ich ja gar nicht gegenreden, aber, nee, ich glaube schon. Ich glaube nur, ich finde es so faszinierend, dass wir bei Zucker gesagt haben, nee, da waren wir richtig. Also wenn sie sagen, pass auf, entweder wir haben noch nicht das Element gefunden, was mehr nach Zucker schmeckt als Zucker, aber ich finde es faszinierend, dass man in süsses Popcorn eigentlich einfach nur Zucker reinbringt. Aber es gibt ja Süssstoffe. Ich habe mal gehört, dass Süssstoffe eigentlich mehr Kalorien haben als Zucker, aber die sind halt dreitausendmal so süss wie Zucker, sodass du davon nur ganz, ganz wenig brauchst. Aber wenn du jetzt so viel Zucker essen würdest, wie du irgendwie hier Aspartam oder was auch immer, wie die heißen, das halt einfach rein essen würdest, würdest du einfach so ein Loch in deine Zunge ätzen. Einfach so einmal durch wie so ein Locher, weil das einfach so brutal süss ist, dass du das gar nicht wahrnehmen kannst. Schreib es dir mal auf. Könnt ihr euch zu Hause auch aufschreiben? Wir wünschen euch eine ganz fantastische, süße Woche. Habt eine süße, herbe, salzige Woche. Schaut mal vorbei auf... Und denkt mal darauf rum. Denkt mal auf der Idee rum. Alle gemeinsam. Ja, denkt mal drauf rum und falls ihr wirklich noch ein Scheinchen zu Hause rumliegen habt, dann schickt ihn gerne. Wir schlafen mal eine Woche drüber. Ja, schlafen mal drüber in der Zeit. Schaut mal gerne auf Reddit vorbei, das Podcast Ufofo, schaut gerne mal auf patreon.com slash das Podcast Ufo.
Wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr uns unterstützt und ihr Patronin werdet und im Club, in unseren Club kommt.
Gerne. Und schaut auch mal auf die neue Website, podcast-ufo.fail, wie immer.
Ansonsten habt eine schöne Woche, viel Spaß, ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin, macht's gut.
Macht's gut, ciao, ciao.
Wir haben ab, ciao, macht's gut.
It's the worst part of production. wieder. Bis dahin, macht's gut. Macht's gut, ciao, ciao, ciao, macht's gut.